hey everyone it's Mike from overflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you can join me for this video
where I'll be talking about imbalances
and you know sort of the the differences
when you make adjustments of your
imbalance percentage now before I jump
in if you've been enjoying these videos
be sure to subscribe to the channel
click the notification Bell so you don't
miss any new upload and if you find
today's video helpful hit the like
button before me and be sure to leave a
comment sharing your biggest takeaway
you know I love hearing your feedback
because today's video is based off of a
user question
so your support really does go a long
way in helping me create more content
just like this so again if you're
getting value from my channel be sure to
subscribe and that way you won't miss
any new videos so let's go ahead and get
started with today's topic okay so uh
Solomon Israel 2256 wrote uh sir please
do you use 300 imbalances different when
trading any Market be it crypto on any
time
or do you change the imbalance
percentage when using different time
frame no I don't make any changes now
you know sometimes people they watch my
videos or see my you know my trainings
and I show different types of charts
different time frames you know I show
range based charts I show a one minute
chart a 30 second chart
Etc and they think oh my gosh you know I
I got to use all these different charts
no you don't I use it to show you that
um you know the order flow analysis
transfers from one market to another it
doesn't matter what type of chart you're
using for the most part right as as long
as you got some usable data then you can
start making trading decisions now when
it comes to imbalances I keep mine at
four to one which is 400 percent 300
percent would be three to one so
let's just open up the order for Trader
software so you see here in Balance
trigger in percent is set to 400. now
in thinner markets okay so this is a
this is a gold eight range chart okay
and
you're not getting tons and tons of
volume right most volume at a level is
somewhere between you know 20 to 50 okay
and if you're looking at another Market
call it uh 10 years
in 10 years I like to use a four range
chart so I'm talking about jumping
around charts but
just really quick just give an idea okay
most of these imbalances that you see
whether you're using
um
400 percent or three hundred percent are
still going to be there
okay
235 against 7 000 is much more than 400
percent much more than four to one 75
against thirty two hundred it's much
more than four to one
where it's going to get a little bit
trickier of course is on some of these
volumes that are a little bit closer so
if I was using
um three to one right 300 percent
I might get
one or two extra I mean this would
probably be a buying imbalance right
here 371 against 1257.
okay right here but at four to one it's
not
so a good way to compare let's just do
this
I will open up another footprint
and put it on the bottom
I'll make it 300.
and just make sure I got it popping in
the right place here I'll do it as a new
panel down here
make sure
it's going to turn off some of these
things so not everything is
going off at once um I don't just keep
it clean here for you guys
that way it's easier to compare keep it
a simple
a simple footprint
there
that don't need this it's easier to
compare this way by looking at it
um
on the same screen
hopefully this will
hopefully this will work
so I got two Footprints one on top
one underneath okay
see the one on top up here is set to 400
percent the one down here is set to 300
percent
okay
and turn off those ratios again I don't
want those extra colors confusing
anybody here so let me just make one
quick change
let's disable the ratios there
so just bear with me here and here we go
okay so you still have this imbalance
but now you've got a buying imbalance
here okay on the way up here you've got
171 against 611.
this is still this this bar is still the
same this bar is still the same you do
have that binding balance here got an
extra imbalance in here this is still
the same
here you got two bind imbalances
here you've got
an extra selling imbalance
here you've got an extra selling
imbalance extra selling a balance
same same
this bar is the same here this bar is
the same this bar is the same so you do
have a few extra you know some of these
that were a bit borderline
okay
obviously
um this one here the 611
this bar is the same this bar is the
same this bar is the same one extra here
this bar is the same buying imbalance
here same bar same bar an extra binding
balance
um an extra
right here 2889 against this
other than that that's so yeah one extra
here you got two extra in this bar
actually two here we got another one
here another selling and balance so you
know you are in generally speaking most
of these bars are the same except for
you know one two
three four
five
that's about it okay but if you're on a
different type of market right so let's
go to change that
back to that but then we'll make it a a
gold chart okay
now since the gold chart right has
you know the volumes are
a bit lighter all right I I just find
you're going to see more imbalances okay
so just really quick you know just
taking it from this bar right here here
you've got one extra
this part is the same got an extra one
this bar is the same same
an extra one in here same
same extra one
same
X the same now you've got a stacked
imbalance appearing in here here you've
got a few more
that's the same
same
more in here you got four now here's
when you only had three you got an extra
imbalance here got an extra buying
imbalance here
got an extra buying imbalance
so
you can see what the differences are
there right again it do you want more do
you want less I just find you know if I
was looking at
this on a and this is a range based
chart if I was looking at a on a minute
based chart
curious how it's going to look here as
well right so here we got three buying
imbalances
okay starting well let's go from the low
same selling and balance extra
you got an extra sign of balance same
get an extra buying imbalance
same same
got an extra bind imbalance same
kind of extra selling a balance
same extra selling and balance same
extra selling and balance
extra buying imbalance same
extrasound and balance same extra
selling a balance
same same
um extra selling buying and balance
same extra buying and balance same extra
selling and balance
extra sign of balance
same these two are the same same
extra buying imbalance
selling a balance
same
extra selling imbalance so you see on on
a shorter Market that trades a bit
thinner volume you're getting more
that's
part of you know the market dynamics of
thinner markets okay
so and again you know I have it set at
10 as a minimum
volume threshold here okay so minimum
imbalance volume I like to set it at 10
because if I don't set it at 10
7 against 0 this is going to be a
selling imbalance but it's only seven
contracts
right which to me is a really enough to
you know to get excited about right I
want to be at least 10 you know eight
against two that would be a sound of
balance but it's not above
10. zero against nine is not above 10.
you know so in my opinion it's best to
have those lines in the sand drawn okay
you can see here right an extra sun and
balance coming in here all right
it can make a difference make a big
difference for you know some Traders
depending on on the market that you're
trading but honestly what it comes down
to is find out
what you're comfortable with
okay I'm perfectly comfortable with four
to one three to one you know it's a bit
weaker five to one would be stronger of
course you know if I went to five to one
I'd have fewer imbalances so let's
change
this bottom one
two five to one okay
so it's from 300 change it to 500. again
it doesn't matter what you're using
whether it's three to one four to one
five to one ten to one a hundred and one
stick with it right and work your way
through the market trade the market with
that be consistent you don't have to
keep changing it so at five to one this
bar has one lesson of balance this has
no sound of balances here you got two
this bar is the same this bar you don't
have that sound imbalance this bar is
the same the same the same the same
same same
one less solid imbalance one less
selling a balance no selling and
balances here
okay same same
no selling a balance here
so again you know I know some people
that that like to use
nine to one
okay if at nine to one it's gonna be
even fewer imbalances
foreign
except for the ones that just really
stick out
oops I changed the top one here
why is this in Balance here I know it's
not going to bounce on the top one I'll
make that back to 400 which is my usual
one the one on the bottom
we'll make uh nine to one sorry about
that I don't want to confuse anyone
but really it's just about finding the
level you're comfortable with and being
consistent with it so four to one on top
nine to one on the bottom okay no
imbalances down here at nine to one just
that one buying a balance no imbalances
just the two buying imbalances
same nothing right this one's got a
selling a balance at four to one it's
not here this bar is the same this bar
you don't have any imbalances up here
you got one buying and two selling
this Bar's got no imbalances this Bar's
got only one but up here's got two right
this bar is the same same
no imbalance
here Etc okay so you can see here you
get three here you got one
here you got one up here you got two
so the point I guess I'm trying to make
is
decide on what you want to use
you know if you're at nine to one you're
getting a lot fewer imbalances obviously
because it's much more stricter three to
one you're going to get more now does
that mean you can get three times as
many more no but you're just going to
get more three to one four to one
I don't say it's irrelevant but it
really just comes down to what you're
comfortable with
you know the guys that you put out
knocked right the old Ninja order flow
Trader are from ninjators they use three
to one they're fine with it
they've been using that for a decade
I use four to one I'm fine with it at
the end of the day it just comes down to
what you're comfortable with obviously a
three to one you're going to get more
imbalances
then at four to one
but you don't need to keep changing it
adjusting it on a market by market basis
you just
find your comfort zone
and stick with it that's all that's all
you got to do find your comfort zone
that's a lot about what trading is about
is finding your comfort zone finding
your wheelhouse I see a lot of Traders
coming into the market
they pay a lot of money
for a quote Guru to teach them how to
trade you know you gotta trade e-mini uh
NASDAQ right mnq or NQ you gotta trade
it like this and then they can't because
it's not suited for them they blow up
their account they think ah trading is a
bunch of
um Crooks out there that's the gonna be
further from the truth it's just really
finding what suits you as a Trader and
go with it
all right so I'll end that video
you know the topic uh on imbalances on
that note
so I hope you found these tips helpful
for your understanding of order flow and
imbalance levels let me know what you'd
like to discuss next by leaving a
comment down below and if you enjoyed
this video be sure to subscribe to my
channel
so you don't miss any new uh upcoming
content that I got coming out and I'll
see you guys on the next video
take care